Jake:
Ohh! Mr. DeVille.
Hi.
What are you
doing here?
Working on Labor Day,
if you can believe it.
We've been holed up
in this office all day.
There's an intruder
in the building.
♪♪
And they're still at large.
Come with me.
♪♪
Christian: I don't think I've
ever been down here before.
Matt:
This is our floor.
It's sort of the nerve center
of the company.
[ Fly buzzing ]
It's very sad.
♪♪
[ Clattering ]
[ Christian screams ]
[ Sighs ]
I have to say
this little hunt
is starting to feel
downright spooky.
We're like
the Hardy Boys, huh?
[ Chuckles ]
No. "Scooby-Doo."
You're Scooby.
You're Shaggy.
And I'm Velma.
She was the smart one.
♪♪
Matt: Well, looks like
the cafeteria's empty.
Whew.
Y-You know what they
used to do in "Scooby-Doo"?
They'd get distracted and make
these really big sandwiches.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
[ Tchaikovsky's "Piano Concerto
No. 1 in B flat minor" playing ]
♪♪
Christian: So you two were
the only ones here all day,
and you worked
the whole time?
Yeah. I guess you could say
work is our passion.
Impressive. I'm a bit of
a procrastinator myself.
If I don't want to do something,
oh, I just start goofing off.
I can't picture that.
I hate it when something
gets stuck in my teeth.
Ruins my whole day.
It always happens to me
with popcorn.
Popped corn?
Oh. Yeah.
I went to the movies
last night
and saw the new
Oscar-nominated
animated shorts with
my friend "Popcorn" --
David Corn.
Anyway, the shorts were --
The shorts were
really interesting shorts.
-Uh, there was --
-Dave is a really solid dude.
Hm.
You know what I'm always tempted
to do when I'm here alone?
What?
Snoop around in
other people's offices.
Wouldn't that be fun?